so the three katata moves we've done the
first one the second one is
this one
isn't quite so important what side you
go
don't bring the elbow over
slide it
close to your body
turn your hand as it goes in
this is done in the tajitsu movement
many times when you're
going in
if they come with a showman you can
deflect it
slightly go past their neck and do a
faster room and eggy
so
we
tied it tight
tied it through
i did see
many people don't realize this
but the catego
we
go this side
many people just think that it's a the
is the longest uh flailing strike with a
joe
gives you the biggest distance of all
the all the movements
a lot of people do this i'll show you
from the back
if you don't like that it's wrong
because
you're just resting it
ready to
do the front part
the idea is that you're supposed to be
protecting your back
so
because i could die from multiple attack
i'm
defending my back
bending my back
what the things we have the things we
have to do you could if you're in a
certain situation go on this side
you see as long as you're protecting
your back because this is what the first
part is
the next part like all aikido should
come from the hips
the hips the pelvis
not the arms
so now
i move forward
and i turn
turn
your aim is to keep doing that as a warm
up for the body but also an exercise to
make sure that you maximize your your
spinal twist
quit allowing the power to release the
joe
not the arms
then it releases it
you're striking their temple if you need
a height to work out
work out your own body height work out
your own temple
i do both sides for escaping
stop it here it's like
as if you're catching a ball
this
wrist doesn't want to be cocked it wants
to be
straight
but you're facing this way but it wants
to be straight not cocked
that way when it comes up
for a ski
in the kumijos
[Music]
that's a tall much
so
watch the feed how the feet work
at the same time as the body
on the last part
finish in a
a positive start not an aggressive one
finished here not
not here
this is aggressive
i'll talk about this in another video
not this
and settled
thomas
great
this would be in the cumin joe you would
raise it
and that's where you follow
that's where you follow your body line
my body line is here
that's where you follow it
that's that's why you don't want it
going too far back
or stop too early you need it to fit
your
your body line
i'll show you once more
keep the body lower
[Music]
and as i've said before about these skis
must be here this is no good cause you
injury if they hit your joe
and this thrusts to their heart
and again your heart if you're trying to
work out at what position you should be
coming
into it from higher
into it
so
always the body line
so do it fast do it slow
study it
and the body must do it
the body releases it not the hands
at this point
the hips
make it fly out
thank you for watching
oh my god